احلى لايت
استاذنك بس اه
استاذنك
يا احمد مساء الخير على حضرتكم جميعا
معلش مره ثانيه مساء الخير على حضراتكم
جميعا ربنا يسعد مساكم وكل ايامكم احنا
بنخصص الحلقه دي ل اا مجموعه من التطورات
المهمه على راسها طبعا زياره الرئيس
الصيني للمملكه العربيه السعوديه هو
هيلتقي المسؤولين في السعوديه وهيلتقي
المسؤولين في دول الخليج وهيلتقي زعماء
عدد من الدول العربيه بالاضافه الى تطورات
الحرب في روسيا واوكرانيا والازمات
الاقتصاديه والهجوم التركي على شمال سوريا
والعراق او اي اسئله اخرى حضراتكم تحبوا
تطرحوها
الاسئله جت سريعا
اييه
مساء الخيرات ربنا يخليك ترمينيتر
ترمنيتر بيسال كنت افكر في موعد البث
القادم اشتقنا ربنا يخلي حضرتك يا استاذنا
ايه رايكم مع الاسماء اللي هي انا ببقى
نفسي يعني ادعوكم باسمائكم احمد محمد
ديفيد يعني فاطمه لو ف- لو كتبته اسماءكم
اكون شاكر جدا لكم خصوصا ان انا احيانا
باجد صعوبه في كتاب في قراءه الاسماء اللي
هي حركيه
اذا كنتم تحب يعني مها بتقول هو ايه اللي
بيحصل في قمه الرياض او ايه المطلوب يحصل
اللي عايزاه الدول العربيه وايه اللي عايز
الصين والله يا مها السؤال ده بالنص هو
موضوع الحلقه اللي انا كنت بجهزها عشان
اعملها النهارده وبعدين الوقت ما سمحش لان
هم تكتموا على القمه الفتره طويله لاسباب
يعني مش مفهومه يعني ما حددوش التواريخ
غير مساءا لكن انا هادي لحضرتك اجابه
سريعه لكن نفس السؤال ده هيكون سؤال رئيسي
في حلقه همم هاسجلها بكره ان احيانا ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى لكن بصفه عامه الصين عاوزه
ايه من دول المنطقه الصين عاوزه كل حاجه
دول المنطقه عاوزه ايه من الصين عاوزه كل
حاجه في تكامل همم يعني همم
خطير جدا بين اللي عاوزاه الصين كدوله
كبيره وبين دول المنطقه اول صور اللي بترد
الى الذهن من الصين عاوزه ايه الصين عاوزه
ان هي تحافظ على مستويات النمو فيها يعني
ايه مستويات النمو يعني النهارده الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي للصين مثلا 18 تريليون
في السنه هو اجمالي ما تنتجه الصين من سلع
وخدمات عاوز السنه الجايه تزيد بواقع 5%
6% فيبقى 18 زائد 5% زياده وهكذا
دي مساله حيويه جدا لاي دوله لكن حيويه
اكبر للدول اللي فيها اعداد سكان كبيره زي
الصين علشان تقدر تحقق ده وده امر مهم جدا
والا هتاخواجه مشاكل ضخمه لانه اذا ما
زودتش النمو هتواجه بسخت داخل المجتمع
الصيني بين الفقراء اللي هما محتاجين
ياكلوا وبين الطبقه المتوسطه اللي اعتدوا
على حياه مرفعه اذا ما حققتش ده كل شيء عن
حرب بالنسبه للصين علشان تحققه هي محتاجه
مجموعه من الاشياء من بينها المواد الخام
المختلفه بتاكل المواد الخام الصين
باعتبارها صاحبه اكبر جهاز انتهي في
العالم
وعلى راس المواد الخام دي طبعا الطاقه
البترول والغاز الى اخره فهي محتاجه بترول
وغاز من دول المنطقه واي مواد خام اخرى
تصدرها المواد الخام كثير جدا اللي
بتصدرها الدول العربيه منها حتى الرمله
الابيض اللي مشهوره بيه مصر اللي بتصدره
علشان تصنيع الشرائح اللي هي السيليكون ده
كل الحاجات الفوسفات في المغرب
حاجات كثير يعني على العموم محتاجه تحديدا
للبترول والغاز طيب تاخدوا ليه علشان تشغل
به الجهاز الانتاج العسل نهائيا بعد ما
تطلع السلع النهائيه محتاج اسواق دول
المنطقه في حاجه الى السلعه النهائيه ديت
فهي محتاجه دول المنطقه كمصدر كمصدر
للمواد الخام وتحتاج الى المنطقه كاسواق
لمنتجاتها الكثيره جدا سواء العاديه او
المتقدمه دول المنطقه السلعه الرئيسيه
فيها تصدير مواد خام وعلى راسها البترول
الغاز هتعمل ايه بالبترول والغاز دول
المنطقه تحتاج الى مستورد الصين بتقول لها
انا مستعد اخذ اكبر كميه ممكنه في مقابل
السنه دي هتعطي للدول العربيه اموال الدول
العربيه بعد توفي احتياجاتها الاساسيه
خصوصا الدول الغنيه بالبترول والغاز عاوزه
ايه من الفلوس عاوزه تؤمن مستقبلها لان
البترول والغاز لم يستمر طويلا عاوزه
تتجاوز المرحله الاعتماد على البترول
والغاز عشان تتجاوزه محتاجه ايه محتاجه
تمويل ومحتاجه معرفه
التمويل بتساهم الصين في توفيره بانها
بتشتري البترول والغاز والمواد الخمره
الدول العربيه وفي نفس الوقت لما الفلوس
دي بتوصل للدول العربيه تقدر تشتري بها
التكنولوجيا المتقدمه اللي الصين يمكن ان
توفرها وبالتالي في شراكه ممتازه جدا
تلقائيه ما بتتوفرش مع الدول الاخرى يعني
ارجو ان تكون الاجابه يعني رغم ان هي مش
قصيره تكون وبقيت الاسئله ممكن يعني
تخلينا نعرض للمساله دي بشكل اكبر اشكرك
يا مها
لماذا تصدر الروس على ضربات اوكرانيا
الاخيره للعمق الروح
في البدايه هل هناك صفقه سريه تحاق بين
الروس والعرب شكرا جزيلا جبير
محمد انا يعني ما اعرفش طبعا ليه تسطروا
معرفش اي هجمات السلام الغربي بيقول كلام
كثير يحتاج الى تدقيق لكن واضح من البدايه
من شهور مبكرا ان في عمليات محدوده تم
داخل العمق الروسي
سواء اللاعبيه لان اللي تم التستر عليه
انا ما اعرفوش
الغرب بيقول احنا لا نساعد ولا نشجع
اوكرانيا على ان هي ضد تقوم بعمليات في
العمق الروسي وده يبدو منطقي لانه لو
الغرب ارتكب هي الحماقه الروس هيعلو
بمستوى المواجهات ربما يصل الى ان هم
يبيدوا المدن الاوكرانيه من البدايه الروس
ما كانوش عاوزين يستخدمه قوه مفرطه لان هو
كان بيطمح في انه يبسط سيطرته ونفوضه على
اوكرانيا مش يمحوها وبالتالي اذا وجد
الروس انه الهجمات في العمق الروسي اذا
الهجمات دي اصبحت محرجه للحكومه الروسيه
اكيد الرد هيكون عنيف جدا وبالتالي في
عمليات الواضح ان في عمليات عمليات محدوده
من الافضل للاقران من الافضل للغرب الا
تتسع فكان في صفقه كل يوم في مفاوضات
كل يوم في مفاوضات وكل يوم في افكار افكار
من فرنسا مبادره من المانيا بعض الدوائر
في الولايات المتحده بتقدم بعض التصورات
لايجاد تسويه
حتى الناس المشاهير رجال الاعمال المؤثرين
زي اي لهم ماسك الشهير كان عنده تصور طبعا
اخذه من دوائر مختلفه انما على
انما على ارض الواقع والمؤكد ان حتى هذه
اللحظه ما فيش اي تصور او اي صفقه كانت في
السر او اي مبادره بتختمر اخذت شكل مكتمل
وبالتالي ما زالت كل الاطراف بتفضل حسم
الصراع في ميدان المعركه رغم انه كل
الاطراف مجهده على امل انه لما تغير
موازين القوه يعني تقدر تحقق انتصارات
كثيره في ميدان المعركه لما تقعد على
مائده المفاوضات تكون واضعها اكثر
همم
كنا بنقول ايه برضه الاسئله
تجري بسرعه اقل شويه بس هي ما شاء الله
الاسئله كثير يعني سلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
استاذ سلطان رمزي بيقول العمله العربيه
الموحده مصدر قوه للعرب ام لا عشان تعمل
عمله موحده موضوع كبير تعمل عمله موحده زي
مثلا العمله الاوروبيه اخذت عشرات السنين
وبازل فيها مشاكل
يعني قوه الاقتصاد يعني مثلا لما جات
اليونان ده مثال مشهور قوي لما جاءت
اليونان تعرضت الى ازمه قدره اليونان
اقتصادها ازاي اقتصاد المانيا ولا زي
اقتصاد اسبانيا ولا زي اقتصاد بريطانيا
لما كانت في الاتحاد الاوروبي يعني تعرضت
الى مشكله لما الدوله بتتعرض الى مشكله
بتستخدم ادوات ادوات السياسه النقديه
واحده منها يعني انا شايف ان العمله
بتاعتي بتضعف انا شايف ان العمله قويه
ارفع الفائده اخفض الفايده استخدم السياسه
الماليه ارفع الجرائم باقل للضرائب علشان
اوصل لسعر عمله مقبول حسب ظروفي لما بتكون
عمله موحده لمجموعه من الدول زي الدول
العربيه كلها ده طبعا ده خيال او حتى له
كتله مكتمله واضحه زي دول الخليج يبقى انت
مش ممكن يكون عندك اي قدره على انك تتحكم
في عملتك الريال ولا الدينار ولا كذا يعني
وبالتالي دي مساله صعبه جدا حتى للدول
اللي هي كانت ظروفها احسن منها عشرات
السنين وما زالوا بيعانوا وبالتالي استبعد
ان ده يتم اكثر ما يمكن ان نحلم به
يكون في تعاون افضل شويه بس التعاون ده
برده مش لان العرب عندهم عيب لان انت
هتتعاون ايه مهم بيتعاونوا بس لما تيجي
تتعاون مثلا الكويت تتعاون مع السعوديه
اقتصاديا هتعمل ايه دي بتصدر بترول ودي
بتصدر بترول الامارات همم مثلا التعاون مع
قطر دي بتصدر بترول ودي بتصدر غاز دي
بتحاول تنوع ثروتها بتستخدم الفلوس اللي
بتقتل من الغاز والبترول وبتحاول تناوع
بها مصادر اخرى ففرص المنافسه تقريبا يعني
مش عاوز اقول اكثر من التعاون ولكن يعني
يعني الظروف المتشابهه جدا
سكانيه اقتصاديا تعليميه ما فيش تكامل قوي
اللي انت متخيله مش زي الصين والعالم
العربي مثلا
احم
مساء الخير استاذ سيد هل على وعليه اموت
وعلي اموت عليك استاذ متابعك انا انا حاسس
انها مجامله بس انا مش عارف اقراها اشكرك
محمد الهلالي يعني انا معناها كده تقريبا
ان انت حابب المتابعه ربنا يخليك ويسعدك
ما مستقبل الروبل الروسي واقتصاد روسيا
المستقبل في علم الله لكن ما اثق فيه
حاجتين الحرب
اجهدت روسيا كثيره زي ما اجهدت اوروبا
اكثر وهيكون لها اثار ما زالت تحت الدراسه
بالنسبه لاقتصادات الدول الثانيه يعني
امريكا بتستفيد من امور حاليا اكثر تصدر
صلاح اكثر لكن ممكن يبقى يترتب عليها
اضرار بعيده المدى على سبيل المثال قد
تفقد الاتحاد الاوروبي كحليف لان
الاوروبيين حاسين ان الامريكان بيستغلوهم
في الازمه الحاليه ودي قصه هنتكلم عنها
بالتفصيل
فاكيد روسيا مجهده لكن في نفس الوقت في
معلومه ثاني المعلومه الاولانيه ان روسيا
اثبتت فعلا ان هي اقتصاد كبير جدا وان
اختصار اقتصادها في رقم الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي اللي هو حوالي 1.6 تريليون دولار
هذا فيه نظر ودي مساله تكلمنا عنها قبل
كده لانه واضح انه في معيار اخر هينصف
الاقتصاد الروسي وهو الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي بمعيار القوه الشرائيه وذكركم من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي اللي هو داخل دوله
الماء بيقس بطريقتين الناتج المحل
الاجمالي بالقيمه الاسميه باشوف اجمالي ما
تصدره الدول من سلعه وخدمات
وقدره بالدولار يبقى دولار قصاد دولار
فلاي ان الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لها واحد
ونصف مليار دولا التريليون دولار تقريبا
فالناس لما يشوفوه يقولوا ده اصغر من
اقتصاد ايطاليا واصغر من اقتصاد اسبانيا
لكن لما تشوف
الروبل بيشتري ايه في روسيا والدولار
بيشتري ايه في امريكا هتجد انه ال ال
القيمه ديه اللي تحولت ل 1.5 تريليون
دولار بالنسبه لروسيا بتشتري كتير في
روسيا واقع الامر ان الاقتصاد الروسي لما
بيقيم بالمعيار الثاني
اللي هو معادل القوه الشرائيه او البرج
سينج باور بارتي بيوصل لحوالي اربعه ونصف
وخمسه تريليون دولار وده رقم مش قليل
بالنسبه لدوله استعدادها حوالي 145 مليون
بالاضافه بقى انه الاربعه او الخمسه
التريليون دول جايين منين من صناعات مهمه
حيويه جاي من زراعات عندهم ربنا
الى اخره في اقتصاد جيد واداره تحالفاتهم
بشكل جيد امبارح بس قرات تقرير انه بعض
الصواريخ اللي الغرب همم بيعمل لها تحليل
بعد ما سقطت اكتشفوا كثير من مكوناتها
مثلا ما زالت روسيا رغم ان المفروض تقدرات
المخابرات الغربيه
اللي بيستخدم في بعض الصواريخ الروسيه جاي
من دول الغربيه
مع انه في حظر عليه ومنعين الروس من
استيراده معناها ان الروس مدبرين حالهم
كم تحياتي ربنا يخليك معك احمد عفيفي اريد
دوك ان تتحدث اكثر عن نفسك تاريخك المهني
حياتك الشخصيه مهتمين والله ربنا يخليك يا
ياسر بس انا باستشعر الحرق في انه اشغل
الناس الحديث عن نفسي ولكن يعني انا يعني
الكلام موجود على يعني مواقع كثيره كثر
خيرهم المهتمين كدهوه لكن على العموم انا
صحفي مهتم من حوالي 30 سنه بالعلاقات
الدوليه
والاهتمام بالعلاقات الدوليه ده شغف يعني
انا باحبه
العلاقات الدوليه انك تحاول تفهم سلوك
الدول تجاه بعضها البعض علشان انت تفهم
سلوك الدول ديت في مجموعه من الادوات
واحد منها ضروري انك تتابع اخبار لكن لازم
تفهم
علوم اساسيه لازم تفهم اكبر قدر ممكن من
التاريخ تاريخ الدول دي ايه تاريخ عامل
حاكم في سلوك الدول هي بتتصرف كده ليه لان
كان عندها اعتبارات تاريخيه شكل التفكيرها
والامثله على كده كثير سلوك فرنسا سلوك
المانيا سلوك اليابان مثلا سلوك همم
كثير من دول العالم وتاثر لسه باحداث
الحرب العالميه الاولى والحرب العالميه
الثانيه لازم تفهم كثير من الجغرافيا
الجغرافيا علم مطلوب مستحيل تهتم بفهم
العلاقات الدوليه من غير ما تفهم جغرافيا
الجغرافيا حاكمه في سلوك الدول زي ما
الجينات حاكمه في سلوك الانسان واتمنى لو
كنتوا حابين انا عملت حلقه قبل كده عن
القصه ديت لكن ممكن نتكلم قد ايه
الجغرافيا لما تفهمها بتخليك تفهم الصوره
كانك كنت مثلا عليك مجهده وحطيت قطره كده
كويسه تشوف الصوره برؤيه كويسه لازم تفهم
اقتصاد بشكل كبير بالاضافه الى عوامل
الاخرى ايه العوامل الاخرى يعني لو فهمت
تكنولوجيا التكنولوجيا عباره عن علم بتحول
الى تطبيقات التطبيقات دي بتغير الاقتصاد
بتتغير العلاقات الدوليه والفلسفه الفلسفه
بمعنى ان في فكره بتسيطر بيتبناها بيقولها
فيلسوف بيتمنى لها مجتمع او دوله فتبتدي
تبقى تخليك تفهم ايه سلوكهم زي الشيوعيه
زي الراسماليه زي سياسات كتير فلما بتهتم
على مدار 30 سنه بتحاول تفهم الامور ديت
كل ما بتقرا كل ما بتستوعب كل ما بتسافر
كل ما بتراقب
بتزود قدرتك على فهم سلوك الدول وهذا هو
الشرف اللي كان عندي من 30 سنه او حتى
الان وربنا يخلي حضرتك السلام عليكم
السلام وعز كيف ترى الاقتصاد الجزائري
سؤال كبير ولكن اول اجابه بسيطه تيجي في
ذهني انه قدرت اقتصاد الجزائر اقل بكثير
من ثروات الجزائر ومن قدرات الجزائر
لسبب ما اسباب تاريخيه كويسه بنتكلم على
التاريخ مازال الاقتصاد الجزائري منفتح
بشكل بسيط على الاقتصاد العالمي ما زال ما
عندوش قدره ااه يعني انه لاسباب تتعلق
يعني يعني بالافكار او الاخم اللي حكمت
الجزائر ان الاقتصاد الجزائري ياخد
انطلاقه اكبر ويبقى ممثل على الساحه
الدوليه بشكل
ينسجم او يعني يعبر عن الثروات الضخمه جدا
اللي عند الجزائريين وعدد سكانها المعتدل
واا امكانيات ابناءها يعني
انت عارف الجزائريين ما عندهمش سوق مال
الجزائريين مش مدركين في المؤشرات
الرئيسيه اسواق نشاه او غيره لانه
معاملاتهم مع العالم الخارجيه محدوده
وطبعا كان في اضطرابات سياسيه لفتره مش
قليله حال الدولار والذهب في الفتره
المقبله في مصر يا عزيزي بالنسبه للدولار
الذهب قصه مختلفه شويه
مصري بيضعف بيضعف ليه لانه مصر بتستورد
اكثر من ما تصدر
وعندها مشكله في الحصول في الوقت الحالي
على ما يكفي من الدولارات لسادات
التزاماتها في اكثر من حلقه سواء على نعرف
الام او اقتصاد نعرف اقتصاد بتتكلم عن
المشكله مصر تحتاج الى في سنتين الى حوالي
48 مليار دولار التزامات عاجله في 23 و24
ومدام احتياج للدولار اكثر مما يدخل اليك
من دولارات فانت في ازمه الازمه ببساطه
انه الحكومه المصريه قدام اختيارين عمور
الاختيار الاول
ان هي تترك الجنيه وشانه اذا تركت الجنيه
وشانه سوف يحلق فوق الثلاثين
هل ممكن يرجع ثاني ممكن ده حصل قبل كده
لكن هتبقى المسائل صعبه كتيره طيب واذا
ابقت الحكومه يدها على انه الجنيه يظل
مثلا عند 25 للدولار الناس هتروح البنوك
بس مش هتلاقي الدولار عند 25 ما يعني ان
هيكون في سوق سوداء ثم لصندوق النقد
الدولي لن يقرض مصر لان في شرط اساسي انت
عاوزني اخرجتك يبقى لازم تلتزم بمجموعه من
الضوابط منها انك ترفع يدك عن الجنيه ده
والصندوق بيقول لهم كده ليه لانه لو
الحكومه اخذت القرض بتاع الصندوق وبعد ما
اخذت قرض الصندوق لان لما بتاخذ القرض ده
بيساعدها انها تاخذ قروض من من جهات اخرى
بدل ما تنفق بها على التزاماتها الاساسيه
دعمت به الجنيه ما هو انت لما تثبت الجنيه
عند سعر اقل من قيمته الحقيقيه كانك بتعمل
الجنيه زي ما بتدعم العيش او تدعم الاكل
او كده يعني ف لا سيب الجريمه مفتوح طيب
لو هو همم يعني اصر على انه يثبت سعر
الجنيه لانه لن يحصل على اي قروض اذا لم
يحصل على اي قروض هيكون في مشكله فالحكومه
الان بتوازن بين المطالب اللي هي عارفه ان
مطلوبه منها مش بس لان الصندوق فرد عليها
لان الظروفها بتفرض عليها كده انه يترك
الجنيه همم بس الحكومه خايفه تتركه فجاه
انها ترفع الدعم عن بعض المنتجات الاساسيه
زي السولار والبنزين وغيره وبالتالي
الفتره اللي جايه هتبقى فتره صعبه على
صانع القرار في مصر
بديهي طالما الجنيه بينخفض قدام الدولار
لازم الدهب هيكون وفقا لسؤالك هيكون غالي
جدا على المصريين لانه بقطع النظر هو
بيرتفع ولا بينخفض في السوق العالمي هو
غالي على المصريين مش لان هو غلب الضروره
لان الجنيه انخفضت قيمته انت بتتكلم في
مارس الماضي كان الجنيه قدام الدولار
حوالي اقل حوالي 15 تقول 16 جنيه دلوقت
احنا بنتكلم على حوالي 30 جنيه في السوق
السوداء ده في اقل من سنه
مساء الخير استاذنا صحيت من النوم بخصوص
على علشان البث ربنا يخليك يا محمد يا
ياسر الله يحفظك ويبارك فيك يا رب
سمعت عن الانقلاب العسكري في المانيا هل
تعتقد انها بدايه صعود اليمين المتطرف في
المانيا واوروبا في حركه والحركات الحركات
الجماعه اللي قبضوا عليها النهارده
متسنليش ان انا اقرا عنها كثير بس من غير
ما اعرف تفاصيلها يعني
تكررت على نطاق صغير في المانيا وفي غير
المانيا
اليمين فاحنا اليمين ال ال اليمين بغض
النظر على المتطرف ديت في حاله صعود في
بعض العواصم الاوروبيه زي ما ان اليسار في
حاله صعود في بعض الدول كما حدث في
البرازيل
اليمين بيصعد هنا وليسار اليمين المتطرف
هنا واليسار العاده مش عارف ليه ما
بيوصفوش بمتطرف المتطرف من نصيب اليمين
يعني
بيكون دائما نتيجه انه الشعوب مش مهتميه
بالفلسفه قوي يعني انت يعني اصل كلمه يمين
ويسار دي لها قصه يعني لكن الشعوب او
المواطن العادي دلوقت في السنوات اللي
احنا فيه فيها دي سواء في الشرق الاوسط او
في اوروبا مش مهتم قوي يعني بالفاروق
الفلسفيه بين اليسار واليمين هو عاوز حد
لان الاحزاب اللي كانت موجوده اللي كانت
بتسيطر على الحرب العالميه الثانيه لغايه
خمس ست سبع سنين فاتت فشلت في السنوات
الاخيره في حل مشاكل المواطنين بقى يبحث
عن البدائل فمره يروح لاقصى اليمين ومره
يروح لاقصى لاثار لكن مش هنوصل لدرجه
انقلاب في المانيا يعني
بارك الله فيك سيد جبيل الله يخليك محمد
علي شكرا لك للاسراء العلمي الله يحفظك ده
اس اي ام او ما مستقبل الروبل الروق احنا
جاوبناه كيف جاوبناه هل تتوقع ان تنجح
الثوره الايرانيه في اسقاط النظام
والله انا بتيجي لي بصراحه معلومات
في شان الايراني بس يعني باساله يعني حديث
افضل ريكورد انت بتتابع شان الايراني كل
يوم كل يوم من الداخل الايراني الكلام انا
انا لما باتابع بعد القنوات الغربيه
والقنوات العربيه زي الحدث والعربيه بس
استشعر ان خلاص النظام فاضل له يومين
ويسقط باقول له ايه القصه المساله فيها
مبالغه قال لي اه فيها مبالغه وان
المظاهرات انحصرت من طهران بعد اسبوعين
منها وانعم في مظاهرات وانه في اضطرابات
ولكن محدوده مش هي اللي تسقط النظام ده
وجهه نظره
انا سالته لاني استشعر ان هناك مبالغه لكن
عشان اكون صادق معاك هي المساله محتاجه
دراسه جيده والدراسه الجيده عاوزه اعلان
محايد عاوزه صحفيين بجد يروحوا على ارض
الواقع ويرصده ودي مش موجوده عندنا لا في
العالم العربي على وجه التحديد ولا في
معظم الدول الغربيه دلوقتي لانها باتت في
حاله خصومه مع ايران وروسيا وبالتالي
دائما الكلام روسيا بتنهار وايران بتنهار
وبالتالي همم لكن لو غاز ليا ان انا اقول
ارجح في انا استبعد ان المظاهرات الحاليه
تؤدي الى سقوط النظام
قد اكون مخطئ لكن هذا من خبره المتواضعه
في احداث السابقه مماثله
لماذا تسمى الثوره السوريه بالحرب الاهليه
يا صديقي ده خالي بيقول لي انا ليه باقول
على الثوره السوريه حرب الاهليه
ده بيسموه سمنتكس يعني ده مجرد الفاظ كلمه
الثوره تبدو في اللغه كانها حاجه شريفه
جميله وكلمه الانقلاب شيء وضيع والحرب
الاهليه تبدو وكانه ما فيش طرف يجب اذنته
هي مسائل يعني انت مثلا معارض ليه الرئيس
بشار في عاوز تسمي من ثار وعليه بالثوره
الناس الاخرين عاوزين يسموهم اللي هم مع
الرئيس بشار او اللحوم بان دول متمردين
وان دول بيتلقوا تمويل من الخارج وان دول
كذا وكذا والى اخره
انا تقديري انه
بدات المساله بمظاهرات عاوز تسميها
مظاهرات عاوز تسموها احتجاجات عاوز تسميها
ثوره زي ما انت عاوز لكن ما حدث انه بعد
شهور قليله كل الدول تركيا اسرائيل دول
الخليج للولايات المتحده ايران روسيا كله
دخل في القصه على امل انه يستخدم ما يجري
هناك لصالحه وتحولت الاحداث الاحتجاجات
المظاهرات الثوره المحدوده في البدايه الى
حرب اهليه همم مدعومه من اطراف خارجيه ده
توصيف لها لا يعني انه انصاف للحكومه ولا
يعني انت قاسم من المتظاهرين المحتجين
كثير وفئات مختلفه وكثير منهم وهم مضطرين
على كل الاحوال يعني
انه يحصل على دعم دوله المال يا تركيا
السعوديه يا قطر الامارات يا مصر يا دوله
يعني
انا ما اعتقدش ان ده وصف يعني يسيء لاحد
ما نتائج انسحاب القوه الكبرى من الشرق
الاوسط وما الذي ستؤول اليه الامور في حال
انعدام الكبير او القياده المركزي للشرق
الاوسط هل تستطيع الدول العربيه اجتياز هو
انا انا شكرا
اللي كان افتتح الاسئله
كويس انت طرحت السؤال ده لان انا اخر حلقه
عملتها كان على انه سبب الفراغ او احد
اسباب المشاكل اللي في الشرق الاوسط في
الوقت الحالي هو موجود فراغ بس انا حسيت
ان البعد يعني من تعليقاتهم انه هو فهم
كلامي على انه الدول العربيه زي ما قال
يعني ما لهمش شخصيه وانه هم مجموعه من
يعني في ناس قالوا كلام قاسي كده يعني ما
يقدروش يعيشوا لوحدهم الا اذا كان في همم
قوه مركزيه بتسيطر موليه امر مش ده بالضبط
اللي كان قصدي ليه ده عامل زي السؤال
الاولاني بتاع الثوره والحرب الاهليه انا
عاوز اوصف حاله مش عاوز احكم عليها يعني
الدول العربيه
مش حاله فريده في ان هي كانت دائما
تحت سيطره او تحت نفوذ دوله كبيره
دي مش حاجه تسيء ليهم ده واقع ما هوش
معقوله تتخيل مثلا انه الولايات المتحده
ومعها كله حلفاء والاتحاد السوفيتي او حتى
في الوقت الحالي الصين هيبقى لو ارادت ان
تمارس نفودا على دوله صغيره في دوله في
مكان ما انها تعجز عن ممارسه النفوس ده
احنا الدول امكانياتها بسيطه وبالتالي انت
في حاجه للعالم الخارجي والقوه الكبرى
القوه الكبرى لها شروط على العموم اللي
انا قصدت اقوله في اللي انت في الحلقه
اللي فاتت واللي حضرتك بتسال عليه ان
الدول العربيه في اخر 10 سنوات لاول مره
بتلاقي نفسها وانا بعتقد ان دي حاجه
ايجابيه ان هي بقت ما فيش قوه مركزيه
مهيمنه عليها فبدات الدول العربيه ديت
تتصرف من تلقاء نفسها في ايه في اداره
شؤونها اداره الشؤون ديت مش ان انت تصرف
تموين او ان انت توكل الناس او ان انت
ولكن انت بتصدم بالدول مجاوره ودول خارجيه
عاده كنت انت بتحتاج الى قوه مهيمنه في
ادارتك للصراعات الاخرى عاوز تواجه ايران
بتستعين بالولايات المتحده عاوز تواجه
دوله جاره مثلا العراق بتستعين دول اخرى
وهكذا فجاه لقيت انه ما فيش احد له موقف
واضح من كثير او باي المنطقه فالدول بدات
تتصرف لاول مره بعيدا عن القوه الكبرى مره
بقى تصطدم ببعضها البعض مره تتعاون مع
بعضها البعض اجابه سؤال حضرتك عشان ما
اطولش عليك
الدول العربيه خلال الفتره اللي جايه
هتعيش فتره من الاضطرابات والقلاق طبيعي
لان العالم كله عايش في الترابات وقلائل
لغايه ما يحصل زي توافق دولي وتهدى
المسائل شويه طالما العالم في اضطراب
منطقه الشرق الاوسط سوف تظل في حاله
التراب
علشان ما تزعلوش وتفتكروا انه يعني ده
منطقه الشرق الاوسط دول يعني احنا اي كلام
بص على اوروبا العملاق الاقتصادي بدون
الدول الكبيره اللي هي في الحاله ديت
الولايات المتحده اوروبا مش قادر تعمل اي
حاجه خالص اي حاجه لما باشوف اوروبا دي
بافتكر وزير الخارجيه البلجيكي وزير
خارجيه بلجيكي مش قادره افتكر اسمه كان
حاجه كده مارك حاجه قال ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي ده عملاق اقتصادي
واء كاظم سياسي ودوده عسكريه يعني تاثير
محدود جدا ده عامل اتحاد الاوروبي فما
بالكم بالدول العربيه يعني
متى سوف تتقر الاوضاع في ليبيا
والله
ما فيش حد له مصلحه قوي انا الاوضاع تستقر
فيها لان ليبيا ديت الارض تدفع
والجيوب تمتلئ والصراع مستمر يعني هي حاله
فريده عجيبه انه بلد ربنا حماه بثروات
ونسبه سكان بسيطه
فالببترول والغاز بيطلعوا من الارض
يروحوا للبنك المركزي البنك المركزي يوزع
على كل الفرقات دول مين يعني اللي هم ال
همم الزعامات
الزعامات الكبيره دي بتلاقي الفلوس
بتوزعها على انصرهم عشان يكملوا الصراع
على امل انه كل واحد يحافظ على مركزه
همم يعني همم ربنا
يتولى الليبيين يعني
هل زياره الصين والله في دول يعني انا مش
عاوز احدد اسامي دول ولكن مثلا بعض الدول
انا
بشوف دول
بعض السياسيين بيرتدوا
يعني ملابس
جدا جدا جدا في شعوب جزء كبير منهم بيعاني
من فقر متوقع واقول ما هو اه طبعا الراجل
اللي قاعد ده ولابس حذاء ممكن ينفق على
اسره متوسطه الحل لمده شهر طبعا لانه
البلد ثروت معظمها بيروح لهذه الزعامات
والباقي بيوزع على الناس فتات يعني
وده مش حل دول العربيه بس على كل الاحوال
اين ترى النظام الايراني بعد عشر سنوات
السؤال محتاج تفكير
مساء الخير استاذ الفاضل هل تعتقد ان
المطالبه باسقاط النظام الراسمالي الذي
كان ينادى به بعد ازمه كورونا وتطبيق
الاشتراكيه بدلا منه مازال قائما ام انها
كانت فتره ومضت
عبد الرحمن
هم حتى يعني احنا برده سؤال يعني عميد جدا
يعني
ايه ايه اللي بيخلي المساله تتطرح الاساس
في القصه انه العالم في السنوات الاخيره
عنده مشكله المشكله دي ان النظام السائد
هو النظام
او النظام السوق بس مش اي نظام السوق هو
اللي بيسموه الليبراليه الجديده
وشكله متطرف من اشكال نظام السوق اللي
بيقول لك الدوله التي تتدخل في اقل قدر
ممكن ويسيب السوق للعرض والطلب النتيجه من
النظام ده اللي يطول شر يطول الشرح مجموعه
كبيره جدا من الازمات كان اخرهم زلزال
2008 ثم ادى برده او ساهم في ازمه
اللي حصلت في 2020 و 2021 بشكل كبير قبل
كده ازمات كثيره جدا فالناس حاسه ده انه
النظام ده ما حدش قادر يخلق ازمات اكثر
مما يخلقه حلول بالاضافه انه برده قدس
الثروات في ايدين عدد صغير وحتى في الدول
الغنيه في اعداد كبيره جدا من الفقره وما
بيبحثوا عن بدائل بس حتى هذه اللحظه هم مش
قادرين يلاقوا بدائل عن هذا النظام في
افكار مختلفه منها ان احنا نرجع للنظام
الاشتراك
منه زي الرئيس الصيني مثلا ودي قصه عاوزه
دراسه الرئيس الصيني افكاره بدا التميل
الى رئيسه شين ان انا ارجع ثاني
[موسيقى]
الصين اللي كانت في الستينات اللي سيطرتها
على كل مفاصل الاقتصاد
وفي افكار وفي ناس مش بتقول مش مغرمه
بالتنظير بس في دول بيقولك والله
خلينا نستغنى عن النظريه على فكره التعبير
ده قاله دينك الرئيس الصيني او الزعيم
الصيني اللي بدا الاصلاح في ثمانيه او 78
و 79 يعني انا ما يهمنيش لون القطه زي ما
كان بيقول ماء والزعيم الصين الشهير طالما
بتستهدفه يعني اشتراكيه الشيوعيه راس
ماليه المهم ان احنا نلاقي حلول للناس
ومن ضمن الحلول ديت ان في الدول وفي
اوروبا موجوده زي الدول اللي بيسموها ولا
الرفاهيه يعني او الرفاها الاقتصادي ان هو
واخد زي طريقه ثالث يعني انه بطبق نظام
السوق اه لكن الدوله بتلعب دور كبير في
انك تاخذ ضرائب تصاعديه
الاخلاق بيدفعوا اكثر من الفقراء بتصرف
على بتعمل تامين صحي كويس بتعمل تامينات
اجتماعيه كويسه بتحاول انها تراعي الفقراء
والنموذج ده كان ماشي وناجح وممكن دول
ثانيه تتبناها لكن طبعا في مصالح النخل في
دول لم تسمح ابدا تطبيق هذه الانظمه
الصين دوله ديكتاتوريه هل يمكنها الصمود
في وجه الغرب الديمقراطي
يعني التعبير اللي انت بتقوله ده ده راي
الغرب يعني محتاج ان احنا
خلدون بيقول فالنعمل العقل في الخبر
الصين دوله ديكتاتوريه بالمعايير الغربيه
انا عاوز اقول لحضرتك ان كل بلد لها
ثقافتها اليابان انا قرات ودي محتاجه ان
احنا نتباينها يعني قريتها وانا صغير بس
محتاجه لو حضرتكم تركوها حتى وترجعوا لي
كنت قرات زمان ان اليابان لم تحتاج الى
ادخال نظام العبوديه ان انت يبقى سيد عندك
مجموعه من العبيد زي ما كان موجود في
اوروبا وزي ما كان موجود في دول كثيره ليه
قالوا لان كانت الطاعه عمياء من العائله
للاخ او الاب الكبير في عنده عبيده
موجودين لوحده والاخطر الصغير زوجه
الابناء كله بيقدس اللي هو رب الاسره
اقول على ده نظام مثلا ديكتاتوري كان نظام
موجود
لثقافه موجوده احنا عندنا في العالم
العربي الجزء من القصه ديت
فانت موظف المساله من البدايه واخذ وجهه
نظر الغرب على العموم الغرب نفسه بقى عنده
مشكله في الديمقراطيه لان احنا
عايشين في مرحله انتقاليه انا مش عاوز
اقرر ما قلته قبل كده العالم بيعيش لحظه
استثنائيه ودي حلقه باذن الله نتكلم عنها
يمكن انا تكلمت عنها في اماكن اخرى مش في
القناه يعني لكن لا استثنائيه جدا في
التاريخ ومن بين همم
يعني ملامح المرحله
سنين واحتمال يجي ثاني هو مش مؤمن
بالديمقراطيه ولا حاجه يعني
ومش مؤمن بين العولمه اللي دعت لها امريكا
الغريبه اللي بعد ما ذهب ترامب جاء رئيس
اه مؤمن بالديموقراطيه لكن مش مؤمن
بالنظام اللي هو الاقتصاد الحر والعولمه
وعاوز يعمل همم يعني همم
همم
اجراءات حمائيه مدى جزء من الديمقراطيه دي
مش مجرد تروح الانتخابات انت عندك
ديمقراطيه وعندك اقتصاد سوء وعندك حريه
انتقال الحركه والتجاره بين البشر امريكا
الخبر اللي بس قبل ما ادخل على الهواء على
طول كان ان هم فرضوا مزيد من التعريفات
الجمركيه والقيود على التجاره مع الصين
امريكا بتتغير امريكا بتراجع قناعتها
فيعني همم يعني
القصه احنا في مرحله استثنائيه وكثير من
الثواب فيها النظر
وبعدين انا عاوز اقول لك على حاجه على
الديموقراطيه اولا علشان ما يكونش في سوق
التفاهم انت لو سالتني دلوقتي حالا انت لو
انت عاوز لو انا عاوز اغير مكان اقامتي
افضل ان انا اروح في دوله فيها حكم قانون
واضح وتحترم القوانين حتى لو اظلم عشان
اعيش ولا تصدر اموالي اذا كان عندي اموال
ولا يتم الاعتداء عليا ولا يتم سجني ولا
هكذا يعني
واشعر بالامان ده وضع مثالي جدا عاده ده
ما زال به يتوفر بنسبه اكبر في الدول في
بعض الدول الغربيه
انما عاوز اقول لك انه الوضع ده دوله
القانون والديمقراطيه المستقره مش كل
الدول حتى لو اردت حكمها ان هم يعملوها
يقدروا يعملوها في سنه ولا اثنين ولا
ثلاثه انت عندك الحاجات دي بتبقى موجوده
مش الحاكم اللي بيعملها يعني ممكن الحاكم
يستفيد من الفوضى وعدم الديمقراطيه في انه
بيكرس السلطات في يده بس انسى الحاكم شيل
الحاكم ده من مصر من السعوديه من الكويت
من السودان وشوف انت الثقافه الديمقراطيه
دي معناها ايه
هل الديمقراطيه ممكن تطبق على مجتمع الزوج
في مثلا بيقهر الزوجه بيعملها على مواطن
من الدرجه الثانيه هل ممكن مثلا انه
الديمقراطيه تتحقق ولا يمكن ابدا رب
الاسره بيقبل جدل من ابنائه من المعتاد من
المجتمع يقبل انه يضرب ابنه او بنته او
زوجته هل من المقبول جدا ان الديمقراطي
تطبق والمدرس يعتقد انه لا يصح ابدا انه
تلميذه ان يشكك فيه يعني همم هل من
المقبول اصلا ان الديموقراطيه تطبق في
مجتمعات مختلفه بيعتقدوا ان الحكم الا لله
وان السلطه ده هبه يمنحها الله لمن يشاء
ويسلبها من يشاء فاذا امن بالشكل ده مساله
الديمقراطيه وتداول السلطه مساله صعبه جدا
انت بتتكلم عاوزه ثقافه مختلفه انما ممكن
تتكلم على
مرحله ابسط شويه ان يكون فيه
فصل بين السلطات الى حد ما انك تتكلم على
انه يكون يعني
بشكل اخر في مؤسسات بتعبر عن مصالح الناس
انها تؤخذ في الحسبان انه مفعل القوانين
بشكل اكبر وده كم مرحله وتستمر لسنوات
طويله يعني ان بدانا
ياريت
[موسيقى]
اسم
عندك من ماذا يخسر الخليج منطقه
انا اعتقد انا فهمت السؤال العبقري العربي
ده اوكي
ده برده انا كانت فاطمه سالت سؤال هو في
صلب الحلقه اللي ان شاء الله احيانا ربنا
هيسجلها بكره وده السؤال الثاني اللي في
الحلقه لا الخليج مش هيخسر حاجه اذا هو
تقارب مع الصين بالعكس سوف
يمارس لافريج او نفوز على الولايات
المتحده المتحده لا يستطيع ان هي طبعا
هتقوم طبعا هتمارس الضغوط لكن انت مسكت
الدول الخليجيه كما ارى الدول العربيه
بعلاقات متوازنه مع الصين ومع الهند ومع
الاخرى الولايات المتحده هتسعى
الاسترضائهم وتسعى لتقديم التناسلات بصفه
عامه تمام يمنعش طبعا ان هي لو وجدت نقطه
ضعف على بعض النخب الحاكمه فضايح همم
ازمات همم تضغط عليهم هتضغط لكن اذا عجزت
عن ممارسه هذه الضغوط هيكون هيكون تقارب
الدول العربيه مع الصين نقطه ضغط للدول
العربيه على الولايات المتحده وطبعا كل
حاجه دول العربيه دي مش حاجه واحده كل
دوله لها ظروفها
يا ريت تعطي جزء من الحلقه عن الاحتجاجات
الايرانيه وعن صحه الاخبار اللي بتقول ان
هناك اختلافات بين المخابرات والنظام
والايراني من غير مناطي حلقه هم بيقولوا
كده هو في ايران ايران دوله عجيبه غريبه
يعني رغم انه هي
يعني دوله دينيه بامتياز
والقرار الاساسي فيها للمرشد وانه ااه لكن
فيها توجهات مختلفه والامن ليه راي
والقضاء له راي والبعض اعضاء البرلمان لهم
رايه وبعض الصحف بتعبر عن قراها بشكل واضح
في اختلافات طبعا بس هو السؤال هل
الاحتجاجات دي وده اللي طرحناه من شويه
كبيره جدا لدرجه ان النظام يتغير
عندي شعور حتى هذه اللحظه وقد اكون مخطئ
من المساله مبالغ فيها في الاعلام الغربي
والاعلام العربي يعني
تحاول روسيا الضغط على نظام الاسد
للمصالحه مع تركيا لتقليل نفوذ ايران في
سوريا لكن ما اخذ بالحرب السياسه
ما اخذ بالحرب يعني
يعني تقصد لو توضح سؤالك يكون
شاكر انجنير محمد انا الاسم مقلوب جدا
بالنسبه لي هل صديقنا انت نفسي انجلينا
محمد نفسه هو اللي معنا من سنوات يا ريت
تقول لي وانت بتقول لي وضح لي السؤال لكن
حتى لو ما اتسناش عشان بس ما ننساش سؤالك
لو ما تسالناش ان انا عرفت اوصل لسؤالك
بديهي انه تركيا مثلا لن تخرج ابدا من
سوريا
يعني مش ممكن هتقعد مع الاسد مثلا وتقول
له والله انا هاسيب كل شمال سوريا هاسيب
همم كل الاماكن اللي انا موجوده فيها
وهخرج يعني لم تخرج الا مجبره طبعا
ما هي الخيارات والثانويه التي تتوقعها
التي توقعها من بوت اللي انهاء الحرب
الحرب صعب جدا انتهاء دلوقتي بس في اكثر
من حلقه تكلمت فيها عن القصه ديت ولكن
شديد الان مش عارف ممكن يكون الحل ايه بعد
30 سبتمبر اللي فات يعني ما فيش حل متصور
يمكن التفاوض عليه الا انه الراجل
يخرجون الشرقيه على الاقل بعد ما ساب
خرسان الغربيه ويخرج من ذا بيروشيه ويخرج
من جمهورتين ونسك ولها نسك اللي هو
الدنباص يعني هيخرج منهم ازاي وهو دمهم
رسمي للاتحاد الروسي اذا عمل ده وخرج وساب
اوكرانيا معناها انه خسر وحتى لو خسر وسلم
بهذه المناطق وبقى في موقف ضعيف الاوكران
هيتلبوك بتعويضات ويطالبه همم من سموهم
مجرمي الحرب وده معناه يعني مش نهايه بوتن
يعني انه يخرج من السلطه ده مع نهايته
وعلى كل المستويات يعني في همم يعني مش
قادره اتخيل خصوصا مع التصعيد الغربي برده
الحرب دي ممكن تنتهي ازاي
السلام عليكم
لماذا لا يتم استضافه علماء عرب من خارج
دوله مصر الشقيقه واخص في الذكر الدكتور
نايف الروضان العالم السعودي في الجيو
الاستراتيجي حتى لو كان عن بعد والله يا
تركي ده
كل اسبوعين بينطرحها
انا مش بستضيف مصريين لانه هما مصريين لا
يعني انا بستضيف مصريين نتصادف ان انا
مصري والاصدقاء او المعرفه اللي بعرفهم
معظمهم مصريين بالاضافه الى صعوبه
شويه
الاضافه عن طريق السكايب واللزوم يمكن
تكون المساله مش صعبه زي ما انا متخيل بس
الحاجات المستقره قوي عاوزه ستلايت عاوزه
صوره اوضح عاوزه لكن هي محل دراسه يعني بل
بالعكس ده انا عندي احد همم الزملاء هنا
عندنا عمرو حجاج زميلنا اللي بيصور
البرنامج من خمس ست جدا الاستضافه
الاصدقاء والمتابعين زي حضرتكم اللي عنده
اسئله احيانا عن طريق سكايب وزوم وتبقى في
مناقشه مفتوحه هي محل دراسه والمساله همم
في عهده الراجل اللي قاعد قدامي دوت ماندو
فانتو اكتوبر
انه تيسر الامور ان شاء الله هي محل دراسه
يعني وهاخذ بها نوم وطبعا اتشرف بالعلماء
من اي دوله عربيه
او دوله غير عربيه يعني مساء الخير
استاذنا الكريم راي حضرتك في العمليه
العسكريه المحتمله لتركيا في سوريا
انا كان في حلقه كامله حتى لما كانت
الاحداث فكرت انه انا اعمل حلقه عن بس
وجدت انه الكلام متغطي تماما في حلقه كانت
فنل بتاعها همم سحب الحرب تتجمع فوق سوريا
همم انا رايي يعني انه الرئيس التركي في
جمله واحده
هو يعني
بيقدم رجله وياخر رجل في العمليه العسكريه
في السعوديه يعني هو بيعمل عمليات
بالطيران بالهجوم بالتوابل المحدود في
العراق ماشي
بس ده مش هينتج عنه
تغيير ديموغرافي في شمال العراق انما في
سوريا
حوالي 30 كيلو في العمق السوري وعلام 900
كيلو متر معناها انه هتحصل عمليه ازاحه له
على الاقل مئات الالاف من السوريين دول
هيروحوا فين هينزحوا على المدن السوريه او
يطلعوا على كردستان العراق المساله ديت مش
سهل القرار بالنسبه للرئيس التركي لان ده
معناها مربك للروس وللامريكان
ولنظام همم في صوره الرئيس بشار الاسد
وممكن يبقى مربك للاروبيين لانه يعمل
عمليه هجره جماعيه في قرار صعب عليه ثم ان
هو برده مش واثق قوي ان هو عمل كده قد ايه
من الخسائر هيتم في جيشه قد ايه هينجح
هيعمل ايه بالمنطقه العازله ديت لان ده
معناه انها تكون احتلال ما انت هتعمل
منطقه 30 كيلو في العمق و900 اا كيلومتر
بالطول علشان تعملها منطقه منها وتزيح كل
الجامعات اللي انت بتصفها جامعات ارهابيه
اللي هم جماعات سوريا ديموقراطيه وهجر
اليها همم او تعيد اليها همم على الاقل
مثلا 500 600 تقول مليون سوري من
المهاجرين انت مش هتنقل همم يعني
مش هتنقل عفش شقه او اثاث انت هتنقل البشر
هل البشر عاوزين يقعدوا هناك هيقعدوا فين
هياخدوا بيوت الناس الاخرين هتعيد الناس
اللي كانوا موجودين طب يعني عمليه معقده
جدا التكلفه الفلوس فهو بيقدم رجله ياخر
رجل واعتقد انه هو بيستفيد من تخويف الدول
بالتهديد بالعمليه عشان ينتزع
همم همم مختلفه
لكن على الارجح مش هيعمل عمليه ولو عمل
العمليه تبقى عمليه محدوده دي المؤشرات
بتقول كده حتى الان يعني وقد تتغير متى
سينتهي عصر النفط في نظر الخبراء بيدوا له
25 سنه 20 سنه يعني في سنريهات مختلفه لكن
مش اكثر من كده ينتهي بمعنى تقل الحاجه
اليه
هل الصين بديل وشريكه اعتمد عليه ويغني عن
شراكه استراليا مع الولايات المتحده لا هو
شيء زي ما انت قلت كده شاريك اضافي يعني
وده برده ده الحلقه اللي انا كنت بتكلم
عليها
توفر الكثير جدا للدول العربيه الى رغبه
في اقامه بنيه تحتيه قويه
الخبرات موجوده عند الشركات الصينيه
وباسعار جيده الصين بقت متفوقه في
التكنولوجيات المستقبل
الطاقه الخضراء اللي هي من الشمس ومن
الرياح وكذا يعني تحليه المياه ممكن همم
الكوانتمبيوتنج او كل العلوم الكمبيوتر
المتطوره كل الحاجات دي بقت الصين فيها
متطوره
انا مستعده تشارك الشرك في هذه التكنولوج
بدرجه ما يعني وكمان بتقدمها باسعار رخيصه
بدون شروط سياسيه ما بتقولوش حقوق انسان
ولا بتقول له همم لازم تطبع مع اسرائيل
ولا بتقول له يعني لا هي عاوزه تعمل بزنس
وبس
لكن لا يعني الاستغناء عن الولايات
المتحده تستغني عن الولايات المتحده ليه
اصلا يعني انت ممكن بتستفيد من وجود قوه
كبيره علشان
تمارس النفوذ اكبر على امريكا مش هتستغنى
عنها ما حدش يقدر يستغنى عن دوله بحجم
الولايات المتحده لكن يقدر
انه يدير علاقته بها بشكل افضل يعني
بتخويفها بان انا عندي بديل اخر ممكن ارجع
اليه
همم
هل هناك مناطق اخرى في دول الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابق يمكن ان تسعى روسيا الى
اعاده ضمها مثل ما فعلت في شرق اوكرانيا
والله انا حاسس بقى انه اي كلام بعد الحرب
الاخيره ديت عن ضم مناطق اخرى بيتهيا لي
هيبقى كلام يعني مش وارد للسنين جايه لان
رؤوس اجهاض جدا في الحرب ديت الاوروبيين
وجهاده جدا همم
اتصور ان دي هتبقى سنه يعني همم مش ورده
بعيده يعني
القضيه الفلسطينيه الى اين في ظل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده وغزه اين موقعها من
الاعراب انا اسف محمد سليم لا اي كلام لا
يوجد اي كلام على القضيه الفلسطينيه ابدا
ابدا لا في ظل الحكومه الموجوده حاليا ولا
طبعا في ظل وجود نتنياهو ابدا ده عنده
شركاءه في الحكومه بيطالبه بطرد العرب من
داخل الاراضي 48 اصلا اما الكلام عن غزه
يعني
تظل الماساه مستمره الى ان يشاء الله بعكس
ذلك يعني
السلام عليكم لماذا لا يتمناها
مساء الخير استاذنا الكريم راي حضرتك في
العمليه العسكريه المحتمله اجابنا عايزين
حلقه لفهم الصين ديموغرافيه واثنين يا
استاذنا زي ما طرحت قبل كده
وتطرح لنا سرد عن فلسفه حكمهم وسياسه
الاقتصاد على فكره في حلقه انت عاوز حلقه
عن الصين هي فعلا محتاجه حلقه
بس هي في حلقه ما اخذتش حظ قوي من
المشاهدات لان هي من الحلقات اللي هي كانت
تعتبر يعني
هل الصين ما زالت دوله الشيعيه لو حضراتكم
رجعولها
اظن والله كانت حلقه جديده وكان يعني انا
بدلت جهد في انه تطلع الحلقه يعني سهله
لانه الكلام عن الشيوعيه والاشتراكيه
والفرق بين الشرعيه والاشتراكيه والراس
الملاهي كلام يعني ممكن يبقى ينفر بعض
الناس
تستحق حلقه ثانيه بس ياريت ترجع لحلقه هل
الصين ما زالت شيوعيه بالبحث في القناه
هتلاقيها يعني وممكن تدور بكلمه الصين
هتلاقيها يعني من بين الحلقات
السلام ربنا يخليك يا صالح ربنا يخليك
احمد هل هناك مناطق
اخرى في محيطنا
هل الصين قادره فعليا اقصد ثقافيا على
خلافه الغرب في المنطقه والغرب مش بيدور
على على وليه امر ده
سحر هي سحر المنطقه مش بتدور على ولي امر
الدول العربيه ودول اخرى دول اخرى زي مين
والله كان في ندوه حلوه جدا عملها
معهد في امريكا انا فاكر الجزء الاولاني
كونسي هو عندهم موقع سمور سبنستيك كرافت
موقع رصين جدا الموقع ده استضاف مجموعه من
الدبلوماسيين الكبار اللي بيمثلوا اللي
بيسموه الدول الناميه بس الدول الناميه
دلوقتي بقسموها جنوب الساوث
الجنوب العالميه يعني على العموم لما كانت
من حوالي شهرين ثلاثه تلاقي ان في حاله
ملل من كثير من دول العالم زي جنوب
افريقيا زي المكسيك زي همم
ماليزيا زي همم
دي دوله منافقه وفعلا الامبراطوريه مازومه
والله بتقول للناس كلام غير منطقي ما حدش
يعني الناس بتتعامل مع الولايات المتحده
انا باتكلم عن الحكومات مش على الشعب يعني
ما الحكومه لانه هو مضطر لكن امريكا خلاص
حقيقه ما انت عشان تكون دوله قويه لازم
تكون برده دوله مقبول اخلاقيه يعني مش انت
عندك سلاح ناوي وعندك فلوس وعندك بتاع
برده ما زال الاخلاق لها تاثير لو مش
مصدقني
تعالوا نشوف ليه الولايات المتحده بتفشل
فيه اقناع الدول انها تمرر قرارات في مجلس
الامن لمجرد ان في دول مش قادره تقبل ان
تجاري الولايات المتحده في نفقه يعني على
سبيل المثال امريكا عماله تقول للصين تقول
لروسيا انت ارتكبت جريمه اخلاقيه بضمك
لاراضي دوله مستقله اللي هي اوكرانيا طب
انت يا امريكا مش نفس الكلام عملته
اسرائيل بطمن مثلا الاراضي الكولاني هي
اعراض الجولان دي اللي اعترف بضمها همم
ترامب وسكت عنها بايضا كانت حجه اسرائيل
قالت ايه قالت سوريا هجمتني في سنه 67 من
الاراضي ديت وانا اخذتها في حرب دفاعيه
ومش معقوله رجعنا ثاني ما هي ممكن تهاجمني
ثاني طيب خلاص صدقني اسرائيل واسرائيل من
حقها يعني نصدق المنطق الاسرائيلي
طيب روسيا بتقول انا
اشعر بالخطر
من المهاجم من هذه المناطق خصوصا كمان دي
بتقدم سبب اضافي بتقول والله الاراضي ديت
شرق اوكرانيا
في اغلبيه روسيه مضطهده والاغلبيه الروسيه
اعلنت استقلالها وطلبت انضمامي سواء
صدقتهم او لا طيب بنفس المنطق اللي يخليك
تقبل منطق اسرائيل
مش عاوز تقبل ما انت في روسيا ما تقبلش
منطق اسرائيل ففي حاله نفاق عنيف نفاق
عنيف جدا
برايك احنا تكلمنا على الهجوم مساء الخير
استاذنا راي حضرتك في العمليه العسكريه
اجابنا سيد على فكره انت ثاني يا اخونا
محمود طيب ماشي على فكره انا انا ما بقولش
اسم خالص في البرنامج هو انا اسمي سيد
جبيل تصغير جبل يعني الجيم جبل
جليل يعني هل ستعود الحرب في اليمن
هناك تسريبات تتحدث عن هدنه غير معلنه بين
ايران وقطر تخفض التصعيد خلال المونديال
فقط
المتحركه
والله فكره مش وحشه انا ما اعرفش ان في
هذه المفاوضات
وتتحدث عن هدنه غير معلنه في الغالب بقى
تقصد بواسطه قطريه يعني لكن عارف انه يعني
الاطراف مجهده هناك ناس بتحاول تحت
اقل قدر ممكن لكن ما زال الوضع هشه جدا في
اليمن يمكن ان يعود مره اخرى انما ما
تنسوش ان العامل الاساسي اللي مخلي الوضع
على هذا النحو انه ما فيش اي قوه محليه
قادره تهزم الحوثيين وربما كمان ما عندهمش
الحافز لهزيمه الحارثيين خلوهم ياخذوا
الشمال وفي قوه مؤثره بتقول خلينا في
الجنوب يعني
وفي دول خارجيه مبسوطه باللي بيحصل على
امريكا ان تعلم ان اسرائيل قريبا ستتخلى
عن حمايه امريكا وتصبح يد الصين في
المنطقه والله كلامك يا وفاء مش يعني مش
بعيد عن المنطقه اللي موجود لدى الولايات
المتحده هي الصين اسرائيل بتقوي علاقتها
مع الصين
في الاستغناء عن امريكا ابدا ابدا انما ده
بيستفز الامريكان حد كبير انه
اسرائيل بقى تتبع سياسات احيانا تتعارض مع
المصالح الامريكيه في علاقتها بروسيا
خصوصا في الحرب هناك في اوكرانيا في
علاقتها ب همم الصين الى اخره لكن طبعا ما
حدش في المسؤولين الامريكيين يجروء بان
يتحدث اسرائيل
ليه ارتو للحلقات اللي تكلمنا فيها عن
العنوان ده بالضبط لماذا يخاف الرؤساء
الامريكان من اسرائيل
السلام عليكم هل الغرب يعيش مرحله سقوط
بطيء كيف ترى مستقبله
ويعني طبعا النوع ده من الاسئله بيكون
يعني استشرافي كبير جدا الغرب لما يسقط
هيسكت يروح فين تقول انه انه السنوات اللي
كان الغرب فيها بيحكم العالم فرنسا
بريطانيا بالولايات المتحده كندا
تراجع قدام صعود دول ثانيه يعني ما فيش شك
طبعا انه روسيا الان مش هي روسيا اللي
كانت منهاره في التسعينات ما فيش شبكه
ابدا ان الصين بقت زي الاخطبوط يعني اللي
هو موجود في كل دول العالم ما فيش شبكه
ابدا انه الهند دوله مؤثره ومهمه على
الاقل في محيطها وبالتالي نتيجه صعود
الجنوب او الشرق في تراجع في النفود
الغربي
شفت كاس العالم ده احنا روحنا فين
شفت كاس العالم ده عبد العزيز وايه رايك
بتصرفات الاوروبيين تجاه قطر هو الجزء
الاول حلو شوفت كاس العالم وانبسطت بيه
يعني كاس ممتع جدا يا ريت كان بقيه الحلقه
كلها كاس العالم انما التصرفات الاوروبيين
ضد جزء من النفاق الاوروبي طبعا ولما
اتكلم فعلا رئيس الفيفا عن النفاق
الاوروبيين هو نفاق واضح زي النفاق
الامريكي يعني هم بيقولوا من الاوروبيين
بيعاملوا
العماله الاجنبيه بشكل سيء خلينا نصدق
الاوروبيين بس كمان يعني الاوروبيين دول
بيستعينوا بعصابات ومافيه في دول افريقيا
علشان تعذب وتمنع المهاجرين اليها بالقوه
يعني
مفيش شك طبعا انه جزء منها ان في دول كانت
تتمنى استضافه كاس العالم وشايفين ان كثير
قوي يعني على دوله عربيه كانت من رعاياهم
ولا جزء من زي الدول اللي كانوا من رعياهم
ان هي تستضيف كاس العالم
وللامانه يعني هم اخذوا همم يعني نظامه
الكاس بطريقه
يستحق الاعجاب
ماذا حصل لاتفاق النووي هل ستعود الحرب في
اليمن اجابنا ماذا حصل لاتفاق نووي بين
امريكا وايران وما هي توقعاتك توقعاتك انه
الاتفاق على هذا النحو لم يتم
وانه يعني في قبل النهارده والله الصبح
لقيت ان في حد من المواقع المتطرفه اسمها
يا رب جئت استون ولا ايه همم
موقع مشهور اسمه
كان كان بلطن اللي هو كان مستشار الامن
القومي للرئيس
ترامب السابق والسياسي الامريكي اللي هو
شديد التطرف يعني كان بيرقصوا في فتره من
الفترات اعتقد جيد استون على ما افتكر كان
كاتب مقاله النهارده بيتهم
الاداره الامريكان تتواطئ علشان تخلي
ايران تصنع القنبله النوويه طبعا كلام
فاضي بس هو الموقع تحريضي عاوز يقول ان
امريكا سايبه الايرانيين وهمم ويوم وراء
يوم بيقربوا من القنبله النوويه يعني
يعني
الامريكان من ضمن الدلائل على ان امريكا
بتقول يعني
في وضع غير رشيد او تاخذ قرارات غير رشيد
ان هي مش قادره تاخذ اي قرار منطقي فيما
يتعلق بايران ايه كان الحل لدوله امتلكت
التكنولوجيا
الحل كان اللي قدمه الرئيس اوباما انا
باتكلم على المصالح الامريكيه ما تكلمنيش
عن مصالح السعوديه ومصالح اسرائيل ومصالح
انا بتكلمني على الامريكان الامريكان
شافوا انه هي اريد امتلكه التكنولوجيا
خلاص افضل حاجه ان انا اوقع معهم اتفاق
الاتفاق ده هذه يلعنهم العقوبات وتاكد ان
هم يلتزموا تحت رقابه دوليه مكثفه
وكاميرات في كل مكان ان هم اللي يصنعوا
السلاح حنه طيب وصلوا الاتفاق ده جاء
ترامب خرج منه لاسباب مش مفهومه
اعتقد انه هو هيضغط عليهم فيعوده على
مائده المفاوضات ما يعدوش على مائده
المفاوضات ودلوقتي اخر تقرير لاسرائيليين
من اسبوع ان هم لو عاوزين يوصلوا للقبال
النوويه يوصلوا لها في اسبوعين طبعا كل
عمليه تقديرات يعني
المخابرات الامريكيه بتقول والله انا مش
شايفه اي مؤشرات خالص على ان ايران حتى
هذه اللحظه لغايه دلوقتي التقدير الامريكي
ان هم بيسعوا الامتلاكس الحناوي هم على
عتب النووي جاهزين الامتلاك ولكن لا يسعون
اليه طب انتم عايزين ايه من الايراني انتم
بتقولوا التقديراتكم هي لا تسال قوي
مشكلتهم ايه مشكلتهم ان هم عندهم القدره
طب هتعمل ايه للناس امتلكوا القدره انت
بتلعب انت بتتكلم على كاس العالم ماذا
تفعل مع فريق عنده امكانيات عاليه تقتله
ولا تعمل ايه انت عاوز تلعب معه بتلعب
بامكانياتك ف- اا يعني الاتفاق مجمد لانه
مش قادرين يلاقوا اي حل من الحلول مش
لاقيين يلاقوا حل يحافظ على مصالح
الامريكان ويحافظ على مصالح اسرائيل
بالدرجه الاولى يعني اللي هي بتقول كلام
غير منطقي هي عاوزه الامريكان
يتدخلوا بحيث ان هم يحل لهم المشكله دي اي
مشكله يغمضه ويف ما يلاقوش هناك قدرات
ايرانيه وده مش في حدود امكانيات همم
امريكا يعني ولا اي دوله ثانيه
السلام وعلى فكره ده راي بعض الاسرائيليين
يعني مش هو ده مش يعني حتى الاسرائيليين
بيقولوا كان الاتفاق النووي افضل حل
وارجعوا الحلقه
تكلمنا عنها بالتفصيل في الموضوع ده
السلام عليكم اي وضع اسرائيل في حاله وصول
الصين لقمه العالم بدل امريكا هي الاسهم
مش بيوصل بمعادي همم صديقنا همم مصطفى
بالنسبه لاسرائيل يعني اسرائيل متوثق
علاقتها مع اسرائيل على كل المستويات
وبالتالي الصين تدريجيا بيزداد قوتها
ونفودها بالمناسبه الكلام ده يعني في
نظريات كثيره برده سن عندها مشاكل كثيره
جدا جدا جدا جدا جدا انما كل دوله عندها
مشاكل اذا الصين تمكنت من حل مشاكلها
الكثيره جدا محافظه على هذا المستوى من
النمو واستمرت في صعودها الى ان الاكبر
اقتصاديا العسكريه في العالم اسرائيل لا
تشعر بالقلق لانه هي عندها علاقات قويه
جدا مع الصين ثم ان هي بتتفاوض مع عصير من
موقع القوه بتقول لها انا دوله وهي انا
دوله عندي تكنولوجيا ثم هتظل اسرائيل على
العلاقه قويه بالولايات المتحده والغرب
احنا كتبنا معظم الاسئله اكثر من ساعه
عشان ما ننزلش في عدد اكبر
طيب
انت حولت التحليل السلام عليكم هل الغرب
اخونا عايد انت حاولت التحليل السياسي
والاقتصادي لشيء ممتع اصبحنا ننتظر حلقتك
بفارغ الصبر الله يعطيك الصحه والعفو
والتوفيق شكرا جدا اياد سؤالي ما هو ميولك
الشخصي بعيدا عن الحياه هل معنيته او
روسيا الرجاء الاجابه مع روسيا يا صديقي
مش لان انا يعني مش لاي سبب غير قناعتي
انا قناتي ان هذه الحرب فرضت على الروس
وانه كان الحل سهل وميسور وعندي ممكن
اتكلم ساعتين على القصه كل ما طلبته روسيا
هو ان تلتزم الدول الغربيه بضمانات مقبوله
على اي مستوى على مستوى اتفاقات سابقه على
مستوى المنطق
بان الغرب النيدو اللي هو معادي
لروسيا لا ياتي الى حدودها ده طلب مقبول
في كل الاعراف واذا كنت حضرتك شايف ان
الطلب ده مش مقبول في كل الاعراف وذكره ان
الولايات المتحده وهنا اكبر ازمه في تاريخ
الاتحاد السوفيتي
الاتحاد السوفيتي بين الامريكان والاتحاد
السوفيتي كانت ازمه كوبايه ايه هي الازمه
انه الامريكان لم يقبلوا ابدا ان الاتحاد
السوفيتي يضع صواريخه على جزيره كوبا اللي
بتبعد عن الحدود او الشاطئ الامريكانيه
150 كيلو ما حدش قال ساعتها من الامريكان
والله كوبا دوله مستقله حره تعمل اللي هي
عاوزها لما حصلتش
وبالتالي امريكا اصلا وهي تدخلك في العراق
ليه هو في افغانستان ليه على بعد 10000
ميل مثلا
[موسيقى]
غير مقبول انه النت يمتد الى حدودي ده
مفهوم جدا مفهوم جدا جدا جدا ولو مش مقتنع
قول لي وانا اديك عشرات الامثله
وبالتالي يعني لا نيته همم استفز الروس
اكثر مما ينبغي وعليه هم خلقوا ازمه وما
زالوا حتى الان لغايه 30 سبتمبر كانت
الحلول موجوده ولكن يبدو من الامريكان
لاسباب سوء حسابات حسابات خاصه بيهم هم
اللي بيشعروا هذه الاسماء لا تصدق ابدا
كلام الامريكان ان القرار في ادزلنسكي لو
عاوز يتفاوض يتفاوض واذا نسكل او الغرب
رفع ايده عنه هل ممكن يستمر في الحرب يعني
اسبوع مثلا
اتانا ريل ستيت ماذا
سيحدث للحريات لو تم تحكيم دور امريكا هل
مصلحه امريكا بحجه حقوق الانسان تتلاقى
مصالح الشعوب المقهوره هل ستتوصل تطبيقات
شبكه ما هو برده ده سؤال كبير يعني اذا
اتحجبت دور امريكا امريكا لو تحجمت هتفضل
قوه كبيره جدا يعني هتتحجبها وتبقى فين
هتختفي امريكا هتبقى في قوه بس كبيره
اسمها الصين افضل امريكا دوله كبيره ومهمه
ومؤثره زي بريطانيا حتى الان دوله مؤثره
زي فرنسا الى اخره انما حكايه ال- حكايه
حقوق الانسان هي جزء من الدفاع عن حقوق
الانسان موجود في قناه كثير من الامريكان
فعلا ارجعوا الحلقه بعنوان لماذا تعتقد
امريكا كانها خير امه اخرجت للناس انا
شارح فيها الفكره
وبرده دي من الحلقات اللي كان فيها يعني
حلقات مخ ابويه فلم تحضر باهتمام كثير من
الناس انه مش حنفي يعني
انما في نفس الوقت هي برده جزء من النفاق
الامريكي يعني
الرؤوف مثلا على سبيل المثال يعني خذ عندك
مثلا الامارات والسعوديه كانت السعوديه
بتنتقد كل يوم لان هي دوله بتنتهك حقوق
الانسان وتنتمي للقرن اللي مش عارف ال19
طيب الامارات دوله مثلا ديموقراطيه همم زي
مثلا
فريق مش كبير قصدك على حريات السيدات وكده
طيب انا اقول لك على حاجه اكتر عشان تعرف
ان امريكا يعني دوله فعلا بقى عندها ازمه
السعوديين عملوا حاجه في عهد ولي العهد
السعودي جم قالوا باعتباره انه اصغر ولي
عهد يعني يتولى عمل
حاجه من وجهه نظر الغرب كانت حلم اللي هي
بعض الحريات للسيدات بعض التقييد على
الرقابه الدينيه وجماعه الامر بالمعروف
والنهي عن المنكر
والسينمات ده كان مطلب من زمان جدا
ويقولوا له مش معقوله هتفضلوا 20 كده في
القرن ال 18 17 طب الراجل عمل لك الحاجات
دي
بعد ما عملها تخيل او كان المنتظر انه ده
لحظه بنوع من الاشاده كمطلب
طبعا هو كان مطلب عنده قطعات من الشعب
السعودي دي حاجه لكن كمان كان عند الغرب
طيب لما عمل السعوديين كده كان راي
الامريكان في العروبه بحاجه ثانيه
هنتكلم عن الحريات وانتم ما عندكمش نفس
قدر الحريات الدينيه ان اليهود والشيعه
والسنه والمسيحيين يحظوا بنفس الحريات هل
معقوله مثلا ان اصحاب الميول الجنسيه يتم
قهرهم عندكم في السعوديه هل من المعقول ان
السيده لازم تسافر بموافقه زوجها دخله في
مستوى ثاني الامريكان اصلا ودول غربيه بقى
لها او دول يعني غير غربيه بقى لها عشرات
السنين اكثر تطورا في الممارسات
الديمقراطيه مش موافقه على الكلام اللي
بتقول كده فما فيش حاجه ابدا يمكن في
نعمان النفاق يعني انت بتطلب من الناس
عاوز تستنسهم على صورتك
لماذا لا تستخدم
57 ودبابات الى
يعني دلوقتي هي اصل هي مش حرب الجيش يعني
مش موجود جيش اوكراني في مواجهه جيش روسي
وبالتالي امريكا تستخدم روسيا تستخدم بقى
الجيل الخامس من الطيران وتستخدم الدمار
الشامل
والصواريخ ال همم الاستراتيجي هي اقرب هم
بيعملوا اقرب الى حرب عصابات اللي قدر
يعمل فرق معه الروس انه تجمعات متحركه
صغيره انه بدا يستخدمه المسيارات اللي
الغرب بيقولوا انه اخذوها من
الايراني اذا كان الكلام ده صح ولا غلط
ده عامل وبالتالي هم مش حرب الجيش كبير ضد
جيش كبير لا هو مع جيش ضد جماعات مسلحه
اقرب الى حرب عصابات ودي مرهقه لانجلش
وعلشان كده امريكا خسرت الحرب في
افغانستان وعشان كده ارهقت جدا في العراق
بعد فتره من وجودها هناك وعشان كده ارهقت
جدا في فيتنام الى اخره دي حاجه اثنين انه
برده الاسلحه المتقدمه ديت
معناه ان انت هتدمر المدن الاوكرانيه وهو
ما كانش في تخيله انه ابدا يفكر في
المساله دي لان هو كان بيحلم انه يمارس
يضم جزء من اوكرانيا او كان يفضل اصلا بعد
2014 انه ما يضمش اي جزء ويكتفي بالقرب
ويخلي جمهورتي الجمباز دول اقليم لا تحكم
ذاتي يبقى جوه اوكرانيا علشان يبقى للرؤوس
نفوز على الحكومه الاوكرانيه من غير ما
يعمل عمليه وبالتالي ما كانش بيفكر ابدا
في تتمر مدن ولا بنيه التحتيه هو لجا
للمساله دي لانه كان عاوز يبقى عاوز
يمتلكها بشكل غير مباشر
ولجئ في الفتره الاخيره لضرب المؤسسات
المدنيه او قصدي منشات الطاقه والكهرباء
والسدود لانه عاوز يوقف الهجمات الاخرانيه
على منشاته يعني في اسلحه قويه استخدامها
في غير محله استخدمها لو هيحارب امريكا
استخدمها لو هيحارب دوله قويه لكن مش في
جماعات او تشكيلات
من الشاويه يعني لو كنت بدك تغير شيء بس
سياسه الدوليه شو بتختار غير السيطره
الامريكيه على ال- اا على النظام الدولي
يبقى نظام متعدد الاقطاب ويبقى عندنا عده
دول كبيره همم بتعمل توازن في المصالح
الدوليه
السلام عليكم ايه وضع اسرائيل في حاله
وصور اجابنا مساء الخير روسيا كانت فعلا
تمثل خطر على دول اوروبا بتمثل بتبقى طبعا
كانت بتمثل خطر زي ما ايران بتمثل خطر على
دول الخليج بس الخطر شيء او التهديد شيء
وانه يعني التهديد لمجرد وجودها شيء وانه
يعني مثلا هي في تناقض روسيا عندها مصالح
بيسموها دوله مفترسه على حدود اوروبا
الشرقيه اللي هي كانت جزء منها كثير محتل
من الاتحاد السوفيتي امام جمهوريات سابقه
فطور الوقت هم حاسين بخطر لانها الدول
صغيره ضعيفه في وجود جرى قويه جدا طبيعي
ان انت بتشعر بالخطر وعلشان تواجه الخطر
ده بتواجه بطريقتين
يا اما ان انت بتنضم لروسيا وتقول لها
والله انا معاكي وان انا تعاون معك عشان
تؤمن شرها او ان انت تستعين بحليف
فبتستعين بحلف انه هو ده اللي حصل
وعليه فهو خطر يعني مش ممكن التعامل يعني
لابد من التسليم بيه زي ما انت في الواقع
الحياه انت تلميذ مش عاوز ادي امثله يعني
يبقى فيها تبسيط انت عندك بتبعث ابنك
الصغير لمدرسه الحضانه والابتدائي هو عنده
زميل اقوى منه بدنيا فيمكن ان يؤذي ملكش
حل مش فيها تقتل الطفل الثاني انت تحاول
تقوي ابنك تحاول همم تتواصل مع اداره
المدرسه انما مش يعني هي طبيعه الحياه كده
شخص قوي شخص ضعيف الوضع في دول الخليج
مشكله دول الخليج مع ايران مش بالضروره ان
هي يعني همم عاوز يتدمر دول الخليج ولكن
دول اصغر اضعف في مواجهه دوله اكبر واقوى
عسكريا فطور الوقت بتشرب القلق يا اما انك
تصلي على علاقتك معها تتعايش معها هي
سلطنه عمان زي قطر او انك تستعين بحلفاء
كما فعلت السعوديه وكما فعلت الامارات
لفتره طويله بالاستعانه بالولايات المتحده
صح لسانك الديمقراطيه ثقافه قبل صح يعني
اه شكرا جزيلا رائد السلام عليكم هل الغرب
يعيش مرحله سقوط بطيء اجابنا هل سيطول
الوفاق العربي الحالي هو مفيش وفاق هو طول
الوقت في قلق يعني زي ما كنت باقول لك انه
في حاله يعني اضطرابات هم جربوا المواجهه
اللي انا مش مجديه
فبداوا في التوافق لكن ممكن التوافق يا
نهار الشهر الجاي او اللي بعده يعني
السلام مساء الخير كان ديانه موجوده في
هذا العالم وما الفرق بين الدين والفلسفه
لا كم ديانه لا اعلم اعرف الديانات
الرئيسيه في العالم اذا كانت الديانات
الاسلام والمسيحيه واليهوديه عندك بقى ال-
ال- همم
البوذيه وهمم كديانات رئيسه يعني في
العالم الهندوسيه
الهندوس اللي موجودين في
في الهند وحدها يعني بنتكلم قرب ال 900
مليون او المليار لكن في حتى داخل الهند
لوحدها في مئات الاديان في افريقيا في
مئات الغيره اللي مرتبطه بقبائل معينه
يعني الفرق بين الديانه والفلسفه كبير جدا
الديانه ديانه واحد بيتبع مذهب فوق ايمان
وشعائر يتبعها بلين لي يعني يؤمن بها ولا
يناقشها دي قناته هكذا هذا ما الفين عليه
اباءنا او هذا ما وجدنا عليه ابانا
الفلسفه بحكم التعريف انك انت تستخدم عقلك
في التفكير ما هو صالح وما هو فاسد وعاده
بيكون في تناقض يعني
السلام مشكور استاذنا على الاجابات
المختصره الشافيه ربنا يخليك مساء الخير
هل روسيا ماذا حصل للاتفاق اجابنا هل وضع
اه وضع سقف
الاسعار النفط الروسي وتهديد روسيا بتقليل
الكميات العاليه العالميه سوف يؤدي الى
ارتفاع الاسعار
انا كنت باطرح السؤال على عدد
المصادر يعني اللي بتفهم فيه النفط وكذا
ولكن الصوره مش واضحه قوي لان سوق النفس
سوق معقد
وبالتالي يعني انا شخصيا لا اعرف الاجابه
عشان ولم احصل على اجابه لكن انت عندك وضع
مطرب دلوقت اسعار النفط
اللي هي عند مستوى حوالي 90 دولار مقبول
يعني الى حد ما لكن ممكن اذا حصل انه
الروس اللي هم محددوش رد فعلهم حتى الان
لاسباب مفهومه اذا هم خفضوا انتاجهم اذا
هما منعوا الكلام ده عن الكتله الاوروبيه
ممكن يكون في اثار طبعا كبيره لكن ده
التفاصيل
مليون برميل بتصدر منهم حوالي خمسه
الخمسه دول جزء كبير منهم دلوقتي بقى يروح
ليه الصين والهند ودول اخرى زي تركيا دول
مش فردين مشاكل عليهم فبيروح اريد البترول
طب والجزء اللي بيروح لاوروبا حوالي مليون
ونصف منهم بيروحوا عن طريق خط
[موسيقى]
خط انابيب
والعقوبات بتقول ان البترول الروسي اللي
يروح عبر خط انابيب معفي من العقوبات فا
دي حاجه غريبه جدا وان العقوبات بتطالب بس
المنقول بحرا يبقى احنا بنتكلم على نسبه
صغيره مش كبيره والمنقول بحرا ده
هيعاقبوه ازاي هيعاقبوه انه هم هيمنعوا
الشركات الشحن والتامين الغربيه من
هتتعامل مع هذه الكميات اذا زادت عن
الستين دولار طيب في جزء هيروح هتحمله سفن
روسيه وشركات تامين روسيه مش هيخضع
للعقوبات وفي جزء ثاني هياخذوا السماسره
هيشتروه مثلا سمسار او شركه في الهند
هتشتريه وتبيعه للغرب يعني فمش عارف يعني
التفاصيل كثيره الحقيقه مساله محتاجه بقى
وقت
ايه هل تتوقع ان يكون هناك مستقبل مبهر
للعملات الرقميه في ظل الوضع الاقتصادي
العملات الرقميه يعني ديجيتال يعني
الدولار بدل ما يبقى ورق ديجيتال ده مساله
مطروحه بس عادي يعني ده انت غالبا قصدك
العملات اللي هي الكريب تو كارنسيس اللي
هي البيت كوين واخواتها وانا
يعني قلت فيها ما قاله مالك في الخمر انا
ضدها من الالف الى الياء لكن لما انا بقول
انا ضدها بتكلم على ضدها كعمله هي ثبتت
انها فشلت عمله كوثيت للتبادل لان هي لا
تحضر بقبول عام في كل مكان هي لا بتقعد
مخزن جيد للقيمه هي مش وحده حساب المعايير
الاساسيه في اي عمله كمان انا ضدها كوسيله
للاستثمار لانها لا ينفع الناس ولا ينقض
في الارض كلام فارغ عشان اشتري النهارده
وهم ب 100 املا ان هو يبقى 150 كلام فارغ
اللي هي ارض ابني عليها ولا هي مسكن اعيش
فيه ولا هي زرع اكله ولا هي ملابسها كلام
فارغ اذا اردت ان انتم تحطوه على ان هو
اصل خاطر في الاستثمار هو اصل خطر بين
قوسين كلام فارغ لكن
البعد مصر من الاصدقاء اللي بتكلم معهم ان
هي بتستند الى تكنولوجيا يمكن ان يكون لها
تطبيقات مفيده على بركه الله دي قصه ثانيه
بقى
الحالي كعمله هي فاشله كوسيله استثمار هي
فاشله
واتمنى ان الناس تبحث عن الثروه في شيء
طبيعي حقيقي بدل البحث عن الاوهام
جدا قال لي انت همم عجزت وانت مش عارف
طب انا عجزت طيب هو يعني لما تعجز وانا
صيحات الجديده في علم الاقتصاد ايه يعني
انا مش عارف ان انا النهارده اقنعك ان انا
اجيب الورق ده واقول ان انا عندي منه
100,000 وحده فلحقوا اشتروه يعني
هو
يعني انا من 2017 وانا
متابعتها زي الطفل الصغير اللي بيسالك
سؤال بريء ايه هي اصلا الكلاب
سالت كل البشر اللي اعرفهم من الجنسيات
مختلفه وهذا ما استقر في ذهني وقد اكون
اختك
هل تتوقع ان يكون هناك تحياتي تقييمك
للعلاقات الاردنيه الايرانيه الحرب على
مهرب المخدرات في ظل انسحاب الروس الاردن
علاقتها بايران علاقات متوتره لاسباب
كثيره جدا جدا انما انسحاب
اعتذر
وجودهم في سوريا
خلى انه الوجود الايراني يبقى اقوى
وبالتالي او على الاقل في بعض المناطق
وخلى في فراغ اصل الوجود الايراني يعني مش
الجيش الايراني ولكن
دوله بتسيطر على هذه الحدود وبالتالي بقى
في انفلات مخدرات وغير مخدرات
الافضل انه ندعوا الله انه
الدوله السوريه تستعد قوتها وتستغنى عن
الروس وتستغنى عن الايرانيين لكن ده طبعا
بيقولوا عليها بالانجليزي
انا هاقف عندي الدقيقه 39
يعني بعد 6 دقائق يا ماندو
واخذ بالك لان انا قفلت على الناس
تحياتي تقييمك ما هي العثرات التي تواجه
السعوديه في تحقيق رؤيتها وما هي وما هي
تحديات كثيره جدا من السعوديه السعوديه
ربنا
بفروه ضخمه عدد سكان معقول عدد شباب ضخم
جدا انما الانتقال من دوله
اعتادت وادمنت
الاعتماد على مداخيل البترول
والسيعه دينيه
معلش استاذنكم
مساله صعبه جدا يعني مساله مش سهله
هتاخد سنين طويله ان انت تقنع الشباب
السعودي
اللي هو يبقى بيعتمد مش على وظيفه حكوميه
وان الخبز مخبوز والماء في القوز وانه ان
البيزنس مش كله تجاره لا ده انا محتاج
صناعه ومحتاج اا توطين تكنولوجيات كل ده
بيحصل بس يعني خطوات اولا تاخرت
وهيحتاج الى سنين اطول وهيحتاج الى مجهود
اكبر وبالتالي التحديات كبيره لكن لحسن
الحظ انه انه جاءت يعني ما هي مصائب
مقاومه عند قوم من فوائده البترول كان في
الارض هذه الحرب يعني رفعت الاسعار
وبالتالي رفعت مداخيل السعوديه
وعظمه من قدراتها
ووضعها على الساحه الدوليه همم رياض بقت
اهم عاصمه في العالم العربي رئيس ال ال
امريكا لما جاء الى الرياض واجتمع بباقي
الرؤساء الدول لما قال رئيس الصيني جاء في
الرياض وجاء رؤساء الدول فعندها مزايا
ولقد قوه لكن طبعا عندها تحديات كبيره جدا
رؤيتك لمستقبل النظام في ايران
والى متى سابقه صراعا مع الغرب الغرب مش
هيغير صراعه مع الايران لانه الغرب اللي
هو المنتخب امريكا لن ترضى عن اي دوله
عليها يعني شوف كده هي رضيت عن مين
وتعاونك معه هتلاقيها تعاونك مع اليابان
والمانيا من اعدادها بس انت بعد ما
استسلموا واصبحوا دول رابخه ليا لا يمكن
ان تقبل على ايران لا يمكن ان تقبر على لا
يمكنها ترضى عنه طبعا بروسيا لا يمكن عن
الصين ده يمكن ان تقبل ان تقبل وترضى
وتوقف حربها عن دوله لم ترفع الرايه
البيضاء
حوار جميل والهمني بالسؤال ده اخونا اس اي
ام او عن رايك في دوله عايش والاستقرار
للعرب من النواحي الامنيه في ظل الحرب
الروسيه من النواحي
بتتكلم على جورجيا جورج تنضم الاتحاد
الاوروبي
تقوم في سنه 2008
جورج
الانضمام لحلف شمال الاطلسي في 2008 وكاله
النتيجه ان روسيا دخلتها يعني حرب الخمسه
ايام
لان انت بتشير الى معلومه انا مش عارفها
فلو في من فضلك اكتب لي يعني ما هي
العصرات التي هل وضع سقف الاسعار الروسي
هل تعتقد ان مصر ستكون سنغافوره جديده في
المستقبل دكتور
سنغافوره بمعنى ان هي تبقى مركز تجاره ضخم
عالمي يعني لا لا اعتقد ان مصر عندها
القدره الغفوره جديده في الوقت القريب
جاهز بعد 20 30 40 سنه 50 سنه لكن علشان
تبقى سنغافوره وتبقى مركز تجاري عندك
موالئ من الجيل الخامس ومطارات من الجيل
الخامس ويبقى عندك تشريعات سلسه وهمم
ميسوره وعندك قطاع مالي سهله رشيق وعندك
نظام قضائي مهمه صعبه جدا هتحتاج الى
سنوات في مصر والدول اللي في اوضاع مصر
انا اثقلت على حضراتكم ربنا يخليكم
ويسعدكم احنا بقى لنا ساعه ونصف انا شاكر
جدا لحضراتكم وبعتذر عن
عدم القدره على باقي على الاجابه على باقي
الاسئله لكن اذا رايتم ان هذا النوع من
الحلقات مره اخرى دائما بتجاوبوني مفيد
ممكن نعمله ان شاء الله حتى مره كل اسبوع
انا شاكر جدا جدا جدا واترككم في امان
الله الى